thank you very much it is a pleasure to
be here god save the queen' you've got
your hand up which is so polite so I'm
gonna come to you first yeah that's
never happened at a rap show before
someone just like oh wait my turn
patiently yeah yeah what's your
suggestion having twin boys I presume
you have twin boys grandchildren
wonderful wait so you didn't have them
who had them your son had we didn't have
them Diddy that's a misunderstanding of
how biology works yeah it was his it was
his and your daughter-in-law wonderful
having twin boys great suggestion thank
you very much I will come to this area
then we got some from the front what do
you guys want to hear after that I like
that we put the lights on just so
everyone can be held fully accountable
for their suggestions when this is a
thing I've asked them to do because
recently when the lights are down people
are like sex and when the lights are up
they feel you know less inclined to
shout those things it's also less
intimidating for me to have men shouting
sex at me if the room is fully lighted
so let you guys over here don't feel
that has any pressure on you having twin
boys is a very good suggestion but you
just got tapped on the shoulder over
there do you have a great suggestion to
say Wow confidence there like yeah it's
gonna blow your tiny British socks off
Chris what is it
Beyonce's nightly routine okay I mean
we're in we're in California you a
stylist do you know any secrets no what
did you imagine it's pretty in-depth
thought that she just kind of goes to
bed and wakes up glowing maybe she just
wakes up like that I was setting you up
for that joke but everyone here is so
out of touch with popular music that
they have no idea that she created that
meme great so Beyonce's nightly routine
having twin boys will come to you guys
in the middle what you want to go wrap
that baby Yoda has been suggested quite
recently I don't take the same
suggestion twice we you the gentleman he
was talking about who tattooed people in
1930s yeah
I like that I was backstage I couldn't
see but I like me I gather I see it
that's it oh oh
Soviet war criminal it's hard to tell in
Britain it's very rude to ask someone
where they're from but in America I feel
people like whoa you like Armenian mixed
with where are you from
you're from Torrance and born in LA
you're doing a very good job of not
using your white privilege this is like
you're tanned and that mustache is I
mean I would assume you owned a white
BMW based on that facial hair and lived
in Glendale which is halo I've learned
some racial stereotypes since moving
here yeah so I'm so so we've distracted
ourselves from this to remind ourselves
we had having once that we've got to
spread the love around we I mean we're
happy to take it what was your
suggestion Harry and Megan's future yeah
yeah you you think we care about those
traitors Wow we've split the room that's
that's it so ok Harry and Megan's future
having twin boys Beyonce is not the
routine you guys what you want to hear a
rapper poutine thank you
I said no food suggestions but I feel
that it is actually a culinary marvel
the first time I tried it I was like
yeah do you like it is the fried cheese
curds or unfried do you prefer unfried
okay cool so we've got space for one
more we've had poutine Harry and Megan's
future Beyonce's nightly routine and
twin boys you guys over here it's a high
bar that's been set I'm sure you can
clear it what's it going to Jeffrey
Epstein mate you can't be a man sat on
your own and say that it is
uncomfortable she won't hurt you want to
lay out of his private island I can tell
you about that I feel like we should add
something to that Jeffrey Epstein didn't
kill himself yeah
the thing is again no one here knows
what memes are so it really goes over
their heads let's add something to
Jeffrey Epstein we'll get an adjective
or something else me selling out the
Staples Center I will change that to be
Jeffrey Epstein selling out the Staples
Center I think that will be fun thank
you very much for the optimism over
there
Wow Wow from Hermosa Beach to the
Staples Center cool this they're lovely
people of the comedy magic club a little
thing called a freestyle rap that is a
rap made up on the spot based entirely
on those suggestions it's not written
it's not prepared we'll never be seen
again
please don't worry it won't be anywhere
near as a trophy bad if you're expecting
a privately educated middle class white
boy to be let's drop that beat my friend
yeah drop it that's what I say I said
drop that beat the suggestions to remind
you having twin boys Jeffrey Epstein
selling out the Staples Center Beyonce's
nightly routine poutine and and Harry
and Megan's future and can we turn up a
little bit as well just a little bit
more before I go to sleep before I go to
bed got to make sure take a thick layer
of makeup off my head you might say that
my skin glows I do report these who
Beyonce that still fit and in the
forties probably I've never looked at
her date when she jumps in bed with
jay-z who's first probably him it takes
ten minutes in the shower Beyonce she
takes an hour admiring herself right in
the mirror she's like damn I'm fine and
I've got a great figure my musics in the
charts that selling now the stadiums she
gets bumped off by Epstein why because
he's rising up the poppy and the Lions
everybody forming now the Staples Center
in lies big cute to get a ticket through
the turnstile to see a guy who likes
having sex with child Ren I'm so sorry
this guy's suggested if you are a
pedophile emptiness the best there is
he's like yeah
big hands touch kids under age on my
lands yeah I'm on my private jet off
they fly I'm on the stage with the mic
look at this guy
Epstein you've got no talent just money
I know the royal family looking for me
like they did I'm Megan and Harry when
they said to the Queen yeah we're out
there we're gonna cow a dark hour [ __ ]
palace were leavin because the British
press is giving us the palace
technically they hounded us they were
like Megan what are you out of 10 not 11
you're ugly we don't light you why'd you
say this British press obviously it's
because they are racist the horrible the
tabloids and the Sun the Daily Mail they
were like oh let's have fun we separate
William and Harry because Kate likes
wills but when making Mary's took the
family what the heck will they - they've
got no money from the people coming
through the name the family was the
Queen the cheese has gone slightly off
slightly out of order why did you put it
in your mouth north of the border you
chew it down slurp all the noise the
only thing you could explain this if
you're having twin boys because the
poutines got the calorie amount that you
need to make sure that they turn now
probably I mean if it's too technically
there's three the twins inside you twin
boys who are real handful make sure
you're healthy and don't
the opportunities by smoking or drinking
sitting on the sofa what were you
thinking you put your feet up yeah I
really go there having twins watching
Mandalorian Yoda baby the crowd doesn't
go wild at the donor baby Yoda
technically the child that's the name of
nobody refers to him why does main
character and Mandalorian not remove its
happens while technically in Hellmuth
there we go team finish as I started god
save the queen
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]